قال رئيس حزب القوات اللبنانيه سمير جاجه
ان مطالبه حركه امل وحزب الله بوزاره
الماليه تضرب المبادره الفرنسيه في الصميم
وكان حزب الله قد رفض قيام اي جهه بتسميه
الوزاره الذين يمثلونه او وزاره الذين
يمثلونه في الحكومه ورفض حضر تسلم المكون
الذي ينتمي اليه حقيبه
الماليه
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه ما الاسباب التي تعطل تشكيل الحكومه
الجديده في لبنان وما دلاله تبادل
الاتهامات بشان المسؤوليه عن ذلك وما هي
فرص نجاح جهود تشكيل حكومه وفق المبادره
الفرنسيه في ضوء تعقيدات الداخليه
والدوليه التي تحيط
بلبنان
بعد ثلاثه ايام من انتهاء المهله الممنوحه
لتشكيلها وفق المبادره الفرنسيه وغداه
اتهام حزب الله الاداره الامريكيه بتعطيل
التوصل الى اتفاق بشانها لا تزال الحكومه
الجديده في لبنان هدفا لم يتحقق وموضوعا
لتبادل الاتهامات بين الاطراف المعنيه بها
داخل لبنان وخارجه وعلى وقع ما اكده حزب
الله وحركه امل بشان رفضهما حضر اسناد
وزاره الماليه للمكون الشيعي وتمسكه ما
باختيار وزراء لهذا المكون في الحكومه
المنتظره قال رئيس حزب القوات اللبنانيه
سمير جعجع ان موقف حركه امل وحزب الله
يضرب المبادره الفرنسيه في الصميم ويدفع
احزاب اخرى الى عدم القبول بفكره مداور
الحقائب الوزاريه وبالتالي تعطيل تلك
المبادره
حركه امل بحزب الله علنا بيقفوا بقولوا
ومبارح كانت واضحه ببيانات التكتلات
النيابيه وبيانات المسؤولين على انه نحن
لا لاا ما بقبل نحن الوزراء الشيعه نحن
بدنا نسميهم ووزاره الماليه نحن بدنا
اياها طيب وبالتالي طبعا هذا كله كله
بيضرب المبادره الفرنسيه بالصميم وكله
بعكس كل ما كان حكي
سابقا وبالتالي وبالتالي وبالتالي اكيد
هذا ادى الى تعطل
المبادره نرفض بشكل قاطع ايضا ان يضع احد
حظرا على تسلم المكون الذي ننتمي اليه
حقيبه وزاريه ما وحقيبه وزاره الماليه
تؤكد الكتله اهميه المبادره الفرنسيه
وتعتبر ان الاداره الامريكيه التي تدعم
مصلحه العدو الاسرائيلي في ضرب استقرار
لبنان ومنع تطور اوضاعه التي تعزز قوته
واقتصاده وفاعليته الاقليميه والدوليه هي
المسؤوله عن تعطيل جهود تشكيل
الحكومه
للمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا اليوم من
بيروت الدكتور لقمان سليم مدير مركز امم
للابحاث والتوثيق والاستاذ فيصل عبد
الساتر الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وينضم
الينا من عمان الاستاذ عمر ع ياسره الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي نرحب بكم جميعا وابدا معك
دكتور لقمان طبعا استمعنا الى تصريح سمير
جعجع يتهم حركه امل وحزب الله ب عرقله او
بضرب يعني بتعبيره يقول بضرب المبادره
الفرنسيه في الصميم هل فعلا تمسك حزب الله
وحركه امان بوزاره الماليه يضرب المبادره
الفرنسيه في الصميم كما
قال يعني مساء الخير يا سيدتي في الوقائع
يبدو لي ان المبادره الفرنسيه طارت شعاعا
وانها باتت في خبر كان وان كل هذا الوقت
الذي يستقطع الان هو في سبيل اخراج نعيها
نعيا مطلقا
ونهائيا المساله في الحقيقه ليست ما يحدث
الان ولكن المساله هي في تشخيص ما ادى بنا
الى ما نحن فيه لبنان اليوم لا يشكل وزاره
جديده لمتعه التشكيل فقط علينا ان نتذكر
ان حكومه السيد حسان دياب التي جاء بها
حزب الله وحاول حمايتها قدر المستطاع سقطت
بعد انفجار المرفا وبعد انفجار المرفا
سمعنا ا اصواتا دوليه متعدده فرنسيه
امريكيه اوروبيه تقول بان قواعد اللعبه
التي كانت سائده حتى ذلك اليوم قد تقادمت
وان على القاده اللبنانيين ان ينهج سلوكا
مختلفا وهذا ما جاء السيد ماكرون مرتين
الى لبنان لاشعار القاده اللبنانيين به
وهذا ما يفترض انهم تعهدوا له به وبالتالي
فمن ينقلب على التعهد الذي قطعه للرئيس
ماكرون هو بطبيعه
الحال
يعطل نعم هل تعتبر مطالبه حزب الله وامل
بما يعتبران حقا لهما وهي وزاره الماليه
في الحكومه الجديده هل تعتبر هذا انقلابا
كما تقول على جهود ماكرون بطبيعه طعه
الحال وهو انقلاب مزدوج يا سيدتي هو
انقلاب يقرا على الحرف المحلي تحت عنوان
ان امل وحزب الله يريدان الاستحصال
من الجهه الفرنسيه الراعيه لهذه المبادره
صق براءه على التهم التي وجهت الى بعض
كبرائهم بتهم الفساد والارهاب واعني
تحديدا الوزير علي حسن خليل الذراع اليمنى
لرئيس ميليشيا حركه امل الاستاذ نبيه بري
ولكن هذا الانقلاب ذو وجه اقليمي ايضا
لانه لا ليس من المبرر بالنسبه لطهران
اليوم ان تقدم تنازلات لفرنسا في حين انها
تتوقع مع الانتخابات الامريكيه ان تجلس مع
الاداره الامريكيه الجديده وتفاوض على
لبنان وبالتالي نحن امام انقلاب مزدوج
يجعل المبادره الفرنسيه في خبر كان ويجعل
اكثر المتوقع ان يعاد تعويم حكومه حسان
دياب خلال الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله الى
ان يتبين الخيط الابيض من الخيط الاسود
على المستوى الاقليمي ط طيب المبادره
استاذ فيصل عبد الساتر
ب المصطلحات التي استخدمها الدكتور لقمان
راحت في خبر كان يعني تبخرت وحزب الله
انقلب على التعهدات التي كان قد تقدم بها
لماكرون
وايضا
يعني حزب الله يسلم لبنان ورقه لايران
للتفاوض مع واشنطن عشيه الانتخابات لماذا
يصر اذا حزب الله وحركه امل على هذا
الموقف على المطالبه والتمسك بوزاره
الماليه الى هذا
الحد مساء الخير يعني في الواقع هناك
تفسير كيفي للمبادره الفرنسيه تنطلق من
عده عده اطراف في لبنان وكان هذه المبادره
الفرنسيه يعني كل يريد ان يفهمها على ذوقه
وعلى كيفه وعلى مصلحته في حين ان المبادره
الفرنسيه لم تاتي بشيء جديد ولم تاتي
لتضرب القواعد المعمول بها في لبنان
والاصول المتعارف عليها في لبنان
فالمبادئ سياسيه ووقائع انتخابيه على مدار
السنوات وخصوصا في سنه سوات الاخيره او
خصوصا في المجلس الحالي فليس من حق فرنسا
ولا من غير غير فرنسا ان تفرض وقائع تحت
عنوان انها تريد مساعده لبنان وهذا ما نات
بنفسه بنفسها فرنسا عن مثل هذا الامر ولو
كان القول على ما جاء على لسان السيد جعجع
بان حزب الله وحركه امل يضرب المبادره
الفرنسيه في الصميم هل هناك يعني من يريد
ان يقنعنا بان الرئيس سعد الحريري والرئيس
السابق الس سنيورا يريدان ان يسميه
الوزراء بحسب ما يشتهي يعني بحسب ما تشتهي
الانفس وبحسب المصلحه وان يفرضها على كل
الاطراف اللبنانيه وهذا لا يعرقل المبادره
الفرنسيه من اين جاءه بمثل هذا الحق هل
لانهما سميا الرئيس مصطفى اديب يحق لهما
ضرب كل القوى الاخرى وبالتالي التمسك من
قبل حزب الله وحركه امل هو ليس تمسكا فقط
لاجل التمسك بل هو تمسك لافها الاخرين
اننا لسنا لقمه سائغه ولو كانت المبادره
الفرنسيه هل هذا هو الوقت المناسب ليفهم
حزب الله كل هذا الكلام الذي قلته ولبنان
يعاني حزب الله يفرمل كل جهود يعني ولاده
ليست حتى طبيعيه ولاده قيصريه لحكومه قد
تنقذ لبنان من ازمته انت لم تجب على
السؤال استاذ فيصل وهو ما سر لماذا يا
سيدتي يوجه اللوم الى حزب الله ولا يوجه
اللوم الى الاخرين لماذا مطلوب من حزب
الله ان
يتنازل لماذا على حزب الله نعم السؤال الى
عيسر لماذا على حزب الله ان يتنازل عن حق
من حقوقه
السياسيه يعني ما الذي يمنع من ان تسلم
وزاره الماليه للمكون الشيعي وهو مكون مهم
في التركيبه السياسيه او الطيف السياسي
اللبناني السؤال لي استاده خديجه نعم نعم
تفضل يعني انا انا انا بتقديري انه
المبادره الفرنسيه سمحت لحزب الله بهامش
من المناوره وهناك اسباب كثيره يعني تفسر
ذلك منها ان المبادره غير واضحه يعني
الطرف الفرنسي يعني تركها بكثير من
العموميات وكانه يعني ابقى الوضع على ما
هو عليه كانه ابقى قواعد الاشتباك وقواعد
وتوزيع موازين القوى في ما بين الاطراف في
لبنان على ما هي عليه فبالتالي رحب حزب
الله بهذه المبادره لانه يسمح له بهامش
المناوره وبالتالي هو اليوم يتحدث عن امور
كما كانت في السابق يدرك حزب الله ان
مشكله لبنان اقتصاديه يدرك ان المبادره
الفرنسيه معنيه وفق مؤتمرات باريس في
تقديم المساعده فلماذا يتخلى عن وزاره
الماليه لذلك هو يريد ان يصر على ان يبقى
مشتبك مع الملف المالي بطريقه او باخرى
لانه يعلم اي حزب بالله ان الخانق الرئيسي
له في المعادله اللبنانيه الان هو العامل
الاقتصادي بمعنى الضغط الواقع على الدوله
اللبنانيه وربما هي ورقه قد يتنازل عنها
في قادم الايام بمعنى انه يناور هنا وهناك
واذا اردنا ان ننظر الى حزب الله كيف ينظر
الى الموقف الفرنسي بمقابل الموقف
الامريكي الموقف الفرنسي فيه متنفس فيه
اكسجين يستطيع من خلاله حزب الله ان يناور
او يتحرك بينما الموقف الامريكي ضاغط
وضاغط جدا ويريد استهداف حزب الله
واستثمار الظروف اللبنانيه لجعله اقل قوه
واقل قدره على الحركه في المشهد اللبناني
تحت عناوين كثيره منها قصه المقاومه فبت
قدير حزب الله يدرك ذلك يدرك ان الوضع
اللبناني صعب يدرك انه جزء من المشكله
وانه جزء من الحل لكنه يستند الى المبادره
الفرنسيه لانه اتاحت له هوامش من الحركه
فلذلك تمسك بهذا الامر لكن هل هذا نهايه
المبادره الفرنسيه انا استبعد ذلك انا
بتقديري ان المبادره الفرنسيه تحتمل
تفسيرات كثيره وقد يتدخل المبادره الفر مع
دكتور نعم لنتحدث عن هذه المبادره
الفرنسيه مع الدكتور اللقمان يعني هذه
المبادره يعني في النهايه هذه مبادره ليست
قرانا منزل ليست نصا منزلا من السماء
بقدسيا ربما يعني تبعد عنها اي اي اي
انتقاد وهناك من يقول ان الدور الفرنسي في
النهايه ليس دورا بريئا نتحدث عن دور يعني
اي دوله قويه دوله نوويه دوله عضو في مجلس
الامن الدولي دوله تنسق مع الولايات
المتحده من اجل نزع سلاح حزب الله يعني
لماذا التمسك هكذا بهذه المبادره وكان
الدنيا يعني ليس فيها الا المبادره
الفرنسيه صحيح سؤالك صحيح ومشروع ولكن
علينا ان نتنبه جيدا بان هذه المبادره
ليست اي يعني حدثا بحد ذاته هذه المبادره
التي حملها الرئيس ماكرون تاتي في سياق ما
اسميه التدخل
الفرنسي في الشؤون اللبنانيه منذ العام
2017 تحديدا منذ ازمه استقاله الرئيس
حريري ثم عودته من الرياض الى بيروت
فعودته عن استقالته فتنظيم مؤتمر سادر
ووضع قواعد لاصلاح الاقتصاد اللبناني
ثم المساعده على تنظيم انتخابات نيابيه
وبالتالي المبادره الفرنسيه ليست كما يقال
بالعاميه مقطوعه من شجره هي تاتي في سياق
مديد وضمن رؤيا مديده لكيفيه اصلاح الوضع
اللبناني وعندما عر انفجار المرفا السلطه
اللبنانيه واثبت بشكل واضح وجلي ولا لبس
فيه ان شيئا من قبيل مرفا بيروت يمكن ان
يكون عمليا قنبله نوويه
ا يعني تدمر بيروت وتقتل
اللبنانيين هناك تغير في المشهد وفي نظره
كثير من الدول للبنان فكل الذين كانوا
يدعون الى اصلاحات بطيئه او اصلاحات
تدريجيه باتوا يقولون جهارا نهارا لا يمكن
لهذا الوضع ان يستمر وهذا ما قاله ماكرون
ولودريان وقاله الالمان وقالته الامم
المتحده وبالتالي هذه المبادره الفرنسيه
جاءت كمحاوله اخيره لتمرير الاصلاحات او
لتمرير مراره الاصلاحات المطلوبه من
المنظومه الحاكمه في لبنان بشكل سلمي
فلبنان دعيني اذكر ليس فقط بلدا
مفلس يرفضها لم يرفض هذه المبادره و ولكن
حزب الله يا سيدتي يا سيدتي حزب الله يريد
هذه المبادره بشروطه اي انه يريد هذه
المبادره ان تمدد شروط هيمنته وشروط
استيلائه على الدوله ولكن كلنا يعرف ان
استيلاء حزب الله على الدوله هو احد
الاسباب الاساسيه
للنكبة ها من منطلق الواقعيه السياسيه
ربما دكتور لقمان ولكن هل هناك ربما يعني
قراءه ربما من الحزب لينيات مخفيه وراء
الدور الفرنسي الذي تتدخل فيه المبادره
الفرنسيه في تفاصيل التفاصيل في في
لبنان بطبيعه الحال لان لبنان يا سيدتي
ليس بلدا مفلسا فقط لبنان في اذار الماضي
اعلن افلاسه نحن على اخر هذا العام مقبلون
على انهيارات اجتماعيه بالمعنى الحرفي
للكلمه نحن مقبلون على انهيارات سوف تترجم
عن نفسها من خلال رفع الدعم من خلال نفاد
احتياطي النقد الصلب النقد في مصرف لبنان
نحن مقبلون على انهيار حقيقي وحزب الله
عمليا يريد ان يمدد فرص يعني المفاوضه
طمعا بان يتمكن راعيه الاقليمي الراعي
الايراني من التفاوض على شروط اصلاح افضل
طيب كل هذه الانهيارات استاذ فيصل عبد
الساتر الانهيار السياسي والانهيار
الاقتصادي والانهيار الاجتماعي وكل هذا
التعطيل اليس مسؤولا عنه حزب الله وقد
يؤدي الامر حتى الى
تنحي رئيس الوزراء المكلف مصطفى اديب قد
يتنحى اصلا عن هذه المهمه
وهذا احتمال يبدو مطروحا بقوه هذه
يا سيدتي يحلو للبعض ان يدخل في بازار
الشعارات كان يستعمل شعارات كبيره ان حزب
الله المسيطر على الدوله حزب الله
المستولي على مفاصل الدوله هو الذي ادى
بالبلد الى الانهيار هو الذي ساهم في
الفساد هو الذي افلس الدوله كل هذا ليس له
اي مستند حقيقي لو كان حزب الله على ما
يقولون لكان حزب الله استطاع ان يقول
للحريري الينا وزيره الينا وزاره المال
وليس لك اي علاقه بان تسمي لو كان حزب
الله المستولي على هذه الدوله لما اسقطت
لما اسقطت حكومه حسان دياب الذي فوجئ ايضا
كما الاخرين بهذا السقوط لهذه الحكومه او
استقاله هذه الحكومه لو كان حزب الله
المستولي على مفاصل هذه البلاد لكان وصل
الى كثير من الامور وضغط باتجاه حاكم مصرف
لبنان واخرجه من من من حاكمته استطاع ان
يحاكم جمعيه المصارف على ما فعلته في
لبنان على ما سرقت اموال المودعين وهربت
الى الخارج الذين هربوا اموالهم الى
الخارج لكان حزب الله ايضا استطاع ان يقبض
عليهم ويدخلهم السجون لاستطاع ايضا ان
اوقف عمليات الاحتكار من كبار التجار في
لبنان كل هذا الامر انا برايي انما هو
يعني مصدر ضخ دائم لتحميل حزب الله
المسؤوليه لان المعركه هي معركه مع حزب
الله او يحاول البعض ان يقول ان الانتقام
من اللبنان تحت ذريعه الانتقام من حزب
الله ف تصبح او يصبح لبنان لقمه سائغه او
مبرر ان يؤكل لبنان لنعد هنا الى المبادره
الفرنسيه الفرنسيون طرحوا هذه المبادره
المبادره واضحه المعالم وواضحه الاسس
وواضحه الافكار ان يخرج كل طرف ليفسر على
طريقته وبالتالي يرمي الكره باتجاه الاخر
انا اقول لك بكل صراحه الكل مازوم في هذا
الاطار وفرنسا مازوم في
البدايه يا سيدتي الجميع قبل بالمبادره
بشكلها العام كما كانال كما قال ضيفك من
الاردن المبادره تركت هامشا واسعا
المبادره تحدثت عن مهام اساسيه لهذه
الحكومه وقالت انها حكومه مهمه الامريكيون
هم الذين يعطلون المبادره الفرنسيه في
اللحظه الاولى التي وصل فيها وصلت فيها
الامور الى مرونه واضحه وكادت الحكومه ان
تتشكل ادخل الامريكيون سيف العقوبات
ليضربوا فرنسا وليضربن الساحه اللبنانيه
ويعطل الحل بوضع اسمي الوزيرين علي حسن
خليل ويوسف فنيانوس على لائحه العقوبات
وعندما دخلنا في الشوط الثاني ووصلنا الى
لقاء بين الرئيس المكلف والخليلين يعني
بين حركه امل وحزب الله وكادت الامور ان
تصل مجددا الى ما يشبه التوافق على ان
يختار من بين اسماء يقدمها الثنائي الشيعي
الى الرئيس المكلف يختار منهم وزير ماليه
وبقيه الوزراء الاخرين
لحقيبتك امريكا على الخط مجددا وادخلت
شركتين واسم قيادي من حزب الله على م قالت
انه على لائحه العقوبات وبالتالي الواضح
ان الامريكيين هذا دخول امريكا على عفوا
بس ملاحظه اخيره ملاحظه اخيره ان
الامريكيين يريدون موقفا من فرنسا يوم
الاثنين المقبل وهذا الذي عرقل المبادره
الفرنسيه مجددا لان الاثنين هناك جلسه في
مجلس الامن سيصار هناك تصويت على عقوبات
على ايران وامريكا تحتاج الى صوت فرنسا في
هذا
السياق دخول الامريكان على الخط استاذ عمر
ع ياسره يدفعنا الى التساؤل عن نقاط
التقاطع او حاله التقاطع بين الدور
الفرنسي والدور الامريكي في لبنان
يعني الموقف الامريكي يريد طرح حزب الله
ارضا يعني يريد استغلال هذه الازمه التي
تمر فيها لبنان لاضعاف حزب الله الى ابعد
حد بتقدير الموقف الفرنسي يريد حزب الله
اقل قوه يعني تحت هذا العنوان يمكن ان نرى
مساحات اللقاء هنا لكن السؤال هل تتكامل
المبادره الفرنسيه مع الموقف الامريكي
بمعنى طرف يضغط ويعرقل ويعرقل وبالتالي
يريد ضرب حزب الله الى ابعد حد وطرف اخر
يقول لحزب الله هناك احضان تعال اليه يمكن
ان نتفاهم يمكن ان يكون هناك مبادره
فرنسيه خاصه بعد موافقه حزب الله عليه هذا
سؤال كبير هل هناك تكامل انا بتقديري ان
الطرفين ربما متفاهمان على شكل من اشكال
التفاهم لكن لا ارى في اسرائيل مثلا ترضى
عن المبادره الفرنسيه او تقبل بها لكن في
المحصله بتقديري ان الامريكان يريدان
يريدون استغلال الحاله اللبنانيه طر حزب
الله ارضا الفرنسيون يريدون ان يكون لاعب
لكن يعطون حزب الله يعني وزنه الحقيقي
قدرته على الحركه وبالتالي هذا الفارق
بينهما لكن في المحصله استطيع ان اقول ان
الطرف الامريكي قادر على عرقله الحاله
الفرنسيه يعني الموقف الامريكي موقفه
لاحظي كيف امريكا عطلت السعوديه اليوم
السعوديه معطله في لبنان لا تستطيع ان
تقدم اي مساعدات حتى اقتصاديه للطرف
الحليف لها بامر امريكي ل هل ترف فعلا ان
الامريكان هم من يعطلون الامور اذا في
لبنان سيدتي دعينا يعني نعود الى بعض
الامور البسيطه فرنسا دوله كبرى صحيح ولكن
الولايات المتحده دوله عظمى الولايات
المتحده لا تقرا لبنان بالعدسه الفرنسيه
الولايات المتحده تقرا لبنان على مستوى
مثلا المسار التطبيعي تقرا لبنان على
مستوى دور ايران في المنطقه وفي حين ان
قراءه فرنسا للوضع اللبناني هي قراءه
بعدسه اضيق حيث ان فرنسا تقرا لبنان بناء
على مصالحها المتوسطيه على استمرار حضورها
في هذا الجانب من العالم وبالتالي لا اظن
بانه اصلا يمكن المقارنه بين الدورين
الفرنسي والامريكي اما بالنسبه نعم الدور
الفرنسي نعم اما بالنسبه لفكره التدخل
الفر الامريكي لتعطيل الدور الامريكي
الفرنسي دعينا نسال السؤال التالي في حال
نجحت المبادره الفرنسيه وبدات فرنسا بجمع
الاموال لاعاده تشغيل الاله الاقتصاديه
اللبنانيه هل يمكن ان نتخيل اموالا تجمع
وتضخ في شرايين الاقتصاد اللبناني خارج
رضا الولايات المتحده
اليست الولايات المتحده هي الطرف الاقوى
في صندوق النقد الدولي الذي لا يمكن
للبنان بعد اليوم ان ينهض دون مساعدته اذا
الكلام عن تدخل امريكي
لافساد المبادره الفرنسيه هو كلام ساذج
ويعني ايديولوجي يريد ان يعلق مره جديده
على الدوله على الموقف الامريكي نعم س
ساتر باختصار هذا كلام الساذج وال فرنسا
ما يربطها بلبنان علاقات تاريخيه القوه
الاستعماريه السابقه ال العلاقات العاطفيه
ايضا وشاهدنا لبنانيين يستنجدون ويطلبون
عوده ال عوده فرنسا الى الى لبنان في
النهايه اذا كانت فرنسا مهتمه الى هذا
الحد بلبنان لماذا لا يعني هل يمكن ان
تتدخل اكثر من ذلك لحمايه مبادرتها
و التحديد على الاقل المسؤول عن تعطيل هذه
المبادره يحق لاي منا ولاي من المشاهدين
ان يقرر اي صوره من لبنان يريد ان يشاهد
هناك صور كثيره هناك صور من تعامل مع
اسرائيل هناك صور من رهن نفسه لامريكا
هناك صور من رهن نفسه لكل عدو للبنان
وهناك صور من انتصر على العدو الاسرائيلي
من حرر لبنان من الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وهناك صوره من حرر لبنان من الارهاب
التكفيري وهناك صوره من يقف بوجه امريكا
ولا يريد التطبيع ولا يمكن ان يقبل باي
مناخ اسرائيلي يفرض على البلد السذاجه ان
نظن ان امريكا هي ربنا الاعلى وهي التي
تستطيع ان تفرض كل شيء سواء في لبنان او
في غير لبنان واذا كان الامر كذلك
لركعت لامريكا نعم انت ربنا الاعلى ونحن
لك س نسجد ونركع ونصلي هذا كلام غير صحيح
لا يمكن للشعوب ان تستكين بمثل هذه
الخفه تحت شعار ان امريكا قويه ولو كانت
امريكا قويه امريكا ما التي حققته ما الذي
حققته في هذا العالم حتى اعتذر لك لانه
وقت البرنامج انتهى شكرا لك فيصل عبد
الساتر الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اللبناني
وايضا نشكر ضيفنا من بيروت الدكتور لقمان
سليم ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا من عمان الاستاذ
عمر عيسر اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ه